you probably know we transmit all our
messages on the internet in ones and
zeros and it's kind of like a morse code
imagine beeps going around the world
these are our ones and zeros what
happens if something goes wrong right
when you're transmitting a message a one
turns into a zero or zero turns into a 1
which means the other person receives
the wrong message well how can we fix
this well we're going to fix this by
turning your message into code words
that's what they're called code words
and these code words are a bit more
distinct from each other the idea is
kind of like the phonetic alphabet have
you ever tried spelling out like a word
or name using the phonetic alphabet
that's the alpha bravo charlie thing the
reason you do that is because when
you're spelling out a word the letters
kind of sound a bit similar they can get
confused the letter b might be confused
with the letter d because they sound
similar but then bravo is less likely to
be confused for delta in the phonetic
alphabet so it helps you transmit
messages without mistakes so let's say
we're trying to transmit something like
a coin toss right hedge or tails when i
get a head i'm going to transmit a 0 and
if i get a tail i transmit a 1. but when
i'm transmitting the result a mistake
might happen so just to be sure i'm
gonna transmit zero zero zero if i get a
tail i transmit one one one then it's
less likely that i'm gonna get a mistake
here because if a mistake happens for
example if i got something like one zero
zero at the other end you know
something's gone wrong because i'm
expecting one of these answers so
something's gone wrong now i don't know
which one it is but i would say it's
more likely to be heads because there's
only one mistake for it to be heads if
it was tails that would be two mistakes
so i might interpret that as heads in
the same way if i received
zero one zero or zero zero one i would
say those are heads if i received 0 1 1
or 1 0 1 or 1 1 0 i think they're more
likely to be tails so that means that
this list on the left gives me all the
messages that i'm going to reinterpret
as heads and the list on the right gives
me all the messages i reinterpret as
tails so it helps me fix mistakes well
we can actually think of this
geometrically think of these zeros and
ones as coordinates coordinates in
three-dimensional space let's say this
one down here is zero zero zero and then
this one would be
one zero zero this would be zero one
zero and if i go up zero zero one and
let's just fill in the coordinates we've
got here zero one one one one zero one
zero one and up here this is one one one
so all the possible messages become
points in three dimensional space now
imagine we have a sphere centered on
those code words so let's have a sphere
centered at zero zero zero and another
sphere centered at one one one and let's
say the sphere has radius one that means
that these messages that are closest to
heads are all contained within that
sphere so a message that is contained
within a sphere is interpreted as the
code word that is at the center of the
sphere now it would be nice if we could
fit more code words in that means we
could transmit more information not just
heads and tails we could transmit more
things so the more code words we can fit
into that space right the more things we
can send i might use instead as my code
words zero zero zero again let's use
zero one one one zero one and one one
zero so i've got four code words they're
packed in a bit more densely but the
problem with that is if i use those as
code words if i have a mistake if i had
then one one one which would be a
mistake it's actually quite close to two
code words so i don't know which one to
pick although i can tell there's a
mistake that's happened i don't know how
to reinterpret the mistake
now that is a more dense packing though
so that is nice in fact if you extended
that packing there forever you get
hexagonal packing which is the densest
packing possible in three dimensions but
let's try another way of sending four
code words so i'm rolling a tetrahedral
die i'm trying to send the result and
i'm gonna either get zero one two or
three zero is going to be transmitted as
zero zero zero zero zero so five digits
i'm gonna have one b
one zero zero one one
two i'll transmit as
one one one zero zero and three i will
transmit as zero one one one one so they
are five digits long they are
coordinates in five dimensional space so
these would be our code words as points
in five dimensional space and then
imagine them surrounded by a five
dimensional sphere as well so if you get
a mistake then let's say i get something
like
one one one one one it would be closest
to three that would be reinterpreted as
three actually i'm going to kind of draw
this out just to show you what it kind
of looks like it's going to be do
two-dimensional of course so these are
going to be our code words so let's say
this is zero here this is a point in
five dimensional space surrounded by a
sphere that's a one that would be code
word two and this would be code word
three this is only a two dimensional
slice of what i've done there but that's
not the densest packing possible let's
see what is the densest packing possible
first of all what's the density of this
packing let's just treat it as circles
here if this extended forever we would
have a packing of circles let's just
create a unit that i can repeat over and
over again and then that will be the
full packing and if i can work out the
density of this unit i've made then i've
worked out the density of the packing so
i've made a little square here and if i
just repeat that square over and over
that means i get the whole packing well
that square contains one circle so the
area of that circle it's pi r squared
isn't it let's say it's radius one so
i'm just going to say the area and then
is pi and what is the area of the square
that i've created remember these are
circles with radius one so it's just two
by two so that's gonna have an area of
four and the density is going to be the
area of the circle divided by the area
of the square that contains the circle
pi over four which is equal to
seventy eight point five percent so
that's the density there and that's not
the best density we can do better than
that you might be able to see we can do
better than that uh a better one would
be this we have the circles here and
then we can fill that kind of dimple
there so we've got this kind of packing
that would go on forever i'm just going
to split it up with using this
parallelogram that is containing one
complete circle just like before and it
will have an area of pipe and now we're
going to look at the i'm just call it a
box that parallelogram what is the area
of that it has a base of two multiplied
by the height with a bit of pythagoras
that's going to be square root of three
so the box has an area of two times the
square root of three and then the
density we divide one by the other which
is equal to ninety 90.7 much better much
more dense so if you can pack in these
code words more densely you're going to
be able to fit more code words into your
space so that is the best density for
circles um let's have a look at other
dimensions because we're going to have
to use higher dimensions for this idea
let's have a look what the best possible
packing is in
all the dimensions that we know of so in
dimension 2 is what we've just done pi
over 2 root three the ninety point seven
percent proven to be the best possible
by a fair tote in the 1940s dimension
three
is pi
over
three route two which is
74.1 percent which was proven to be the
best possible by thomas hales in the
1990s the best we found in dimension 4
pi squared over 16. that's 61.7 percent
in dimension five pi squared over 15
root two forty six point five percent in
dimension six the best possible is pi
cubed over forty eight root three which
is thirty seven point three percent for
dimension 2 we've absolutely proved it
dimension 3 we've absolutely proved it
the ones i've shown you so far best
known 7 is pi cubed over 105 which is
29.5 percent and now in dimension eight
the best known is pi to the four over
three hundred and eighty four the
density of that is
25.4 percent in 2016 this was proven to
be the best possible by marina viazoska
not that long ago and that's because in
dimension 8 there is a particular
structure it's called e8 it has a name
where the gaps become big enough that
you can start to fit in extra spheres
into those gaps and then the structure
becomes rigid again and then you get
this properly dense packing but it's
also been proven to be the densest
possible including regular and irregular
packings when they did that they very
quickly then showed that you can do the
same thing in dimension 24. and in
dimension 24 they showed that the best
packing
is pi
to the 12 over 12 factorial
0.19 percent and that structure is a
regular structure called the leech
lattice and john leach who came up with
this leech lattice in in the 1960s was
actually studying error correcting codes
when he discovered this structure but it
was marina and others that showed that
this structure was also the densest
possible in dimension 24. in dimension
24 that's
that's not very dense is it it's not
dense it's not very dense however
we do use dimension 24 the leech lattice
or e8 in dimension 8 we do use those
structures in error correcting codes
that we use today to transmit our
messages yeah so every message is
transmitted with this kind of idea uh so
i mean i was talking about rolling a die
or just sending heads and tails but yes
if you're sending a message on the
internet so you're sending an email so
your the letters of the message uh gets
turned into a number
which is not that complicated a's one
b's two z is 26. then you transmit that
number uh now you could just transmit
that as a binary number if you want to
which is kind of how ascii works or
you can use this bit of a code word idea
have a bit of extra redundancy in there
just so that mistakes don't happen along
the way
[Music]
so this was the third part in a trilogy
of sphere videos and they were brought
to you by brilliant brilliant is an
excellent site it's full of puzzles and
quizzes all about science and
mathematics computer science all
designed to really help improve the way
you think but one of my favorite things
on the site are their problems of the
week have a look at these these are just
for one week you can see there are
beginners intermediate advanced
you can try and answer them but you can
also go down below to a discussion in
the community all about the problems
it's really great
go to brilliant.org slash number file to
have a look at the site there's loads of
free stuff but if you use that url slash
number file you can also get a 20
discount on their premium service which
unlocks all the good stuff i'll also
include a link in the description to the
problems of the week so you can check
them out our thanks to brilliant for
supporting this trilogy of videos all
about spheres